we're continuing to learn more
from this forthcoming book by carol
lenig
and philip rucker from the washington
post
and it seems like it's almost every day
we get
something new from this book but the
latest one is based on excerpts that now
point out
uh that donald trump talked to carol
lennog and philip rucker
so this is actually super super
interesting
um trump granted the authors of this new
book
an hours long interview the book is
called i alone can fix it
now you might be wondering why exactly
would he do that and um
they actually talk about this uh
in this vanity fair piece where they
point out
donald trump previously turned down
speaking to them for a prior book this
time
he wanted to talk to them and they
actually say trump had invited us
to mar-a-lago let me make sure we have
this on screen trump had invited us to
mar-a-lago to interview him for this
book
he had declined an interview for our
first book about his presidency
and when a very stable genius was
published in january of 2020
attacked us personally and branded our
reporting a work of fiction
but trump was quick to agree to our
request this time he sought to curate
history
listen to this as we sat for the
interview the president's
former president's press secretary
presented us with a with copies of a
bound
volume one thousand accomplishments of
president donald j
trump highlights of the first term on
the back cover is the american flag
the presidential seal and trump's thick
jagged signature
the book totals 92 pages and is
organized with chapters
dedicated to the economy tax cuts
deregulation trade and so on
trump walked into the room flanked by
plainclothed secret service
a much smaller detail than he once had
he wore his dark suit and tie his bronze
makeup whatever okay here's the relevant
section
uh that i want to um show you
which goes to trump's latest his biggest
regret
this is absolutely fascinating and very
very scary
over the years trump rarely has
expressed
misgivings but he regrets his response
to protests last summer in minneapolis
portland seattle and other cities now
you might hear that and say
oh maybe he regrets threatening to send
in military
maybe he regrets the despicable things
he said about protesters or defending
the police
uh brutality no no no no i think if i
had to do it again
i would have brought in the military
immediately
he said what if he had another
opportunity
he would have more quickly scaled up the
violence
and the repression of the protesters by
the military
remember when he was thinking about this
that i and others said okay so hold on a
second
you have protests triggered by excessive
use of force by law enforcement against
george floyd that
that was the catalyst for these protests
trump's
natural instinct is to send in military
to shut down the protests which were
overwhelmingly peaceful
that is truly the tendency
the knee-jerk reaction of an
authoritarian it's a horrible thing now
ultimately it didn't end up going down
that way and that's a very good thing
and get
having a chance to do it over again
trump says i wish i had sent in the
military more quickly
trump had they go on to say trump had no
such second thoughts about his handling
of the pandemic
he said he had been very tough in
protecting the country by restricting
travel first from china then europe
he said he did so against the wishes of
his top medical advisors in fact
most of them agreed with the
restrictions before he made the decision
that's true
according to participants in the
discussions and their contemporaneous
notes
but he correctly said he pushed
scientists at the fda
at a level that they have never been
pushed before to get vaccines approved
in record time trump may have been
pushing people
but uh there is no reason to believe
based on everything we know
that trump had anything to do with these
vaccines being approved any quicker than
they would have been without them
this is just a delusion one last bit of
flavor quote
i think we did a great job on covid and
it hasn't been recognized trump said
noting other countries saw spikes in
covet infections in the months after he
left office
the cupboards were bare we didn't have
gowns
we didn't have masks we didn't have
ventilators
we didn't have anything we brought in
plane loads
we did a great job when we asked trump
why he encouraged people to believe
things that weren't true
or to distrust science and the media he
delighted
in talking about the scientific smarts
in his family's genes can you imagine
first of all i'm a big person do you
know this my uncle dr
john trump i think he was at the
massachusetts institute of technology
longer than any other professor totally
brilliant man he had numerous degrees so
that's in the genes
i always go with that stuff but it's a
little bit in the genes
and dr john trump he was a great guy now
i'm a big believer in science if i
wasn't you wouldn't have a vaccine
it depends are you talking about
disinformation or are you talking about
lies
there's a more beautiful word called
disinformation
so i trump seems to be saying he didn't
lie but he did spread
disinformation which i don't know that
it actually makes it any better
horrifying and delusional and what's
very interesting is as they point out
trump never apologizes for anything
trump doesn't have regrets
never here you finally get him to i
guess reflect and say there is something
i wish i would have done differently
i wish i would have sent in troops to
repress protests
about police brutality more quickly just
absolutely horrifying and dystopian
in absolutely every sense of the word
one of our sponsors today is
bluechu a unique online service
delivering
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction
of the cost and they're giving my
audience an entire month
supply for free so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost
of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping